bonjour à tous je suis ravi d'être ici
vous pour participer au thé d'aix mais
aussi pour parler aux jeunes pour parler
de nos parcours je repasse juste après
un chef d'orchestre dans dans la
renommée est internationale et donc pour
moi aussi j'aimerais peut-être partager
un parcours un parcours dans la
thématique était image de marque et
l'importance des réseaux pourquoi parce
que au fait dans notre vie en cumul des
expériences et ces expériences là ne
font que nous renforcer et nous donner
un petit peu une expérience qui nous qui
pisse qui puisse nous orienter dans la
vie et je vais peut-être commencer par
la force des réseaux
pourquoi parce que le mandoul univers
remontiez est connecté un ça va
des atomes et molécules aux des choses
un peu plus complexe et dans notre vie
on suit un cursus dans quand on est
élevé à la maison puis ensuite en
intègre soit la crèche soit l'école ej
10 c et des cursus supérieur puis vient
le monde professionnel est en fait c'est
une phase très importante la phase de
formation et j'imagine que on a tous eu
des camarades de classe
et ensuite
des étudiants des binômes à l'université
réaliser des projets et il s'avère que
pour moi ma jeunesse c'était un peu un
peu riches parce qu'en sait on a dû se
déplacer en famille et donc j'ai
peut-être quelques 500 camarades de
classe en changeant d'école en école on
arriva à connaître beaucoup de monde et
ces gens là vont faire partie de votre
vie sauf si en exil inex dont on veut
plus parler mais c'est important et donc
à un moment donné il m'est arrivé une
expérience qui m'a marqué je voudrais
pas que que les jeunes puissent avoir la
même ou raisonner de la sorte il s'avère
que en finissant mes études j'ai intégré
un organisme international qui est où un
trade center et je reviendrai sur le
point de vue on trade center et donc
c'est beaucoup de travail c'est du
stress permanent c'est la cigarette et
nous arrive par moment d'avoir des
malaises et donc un soir j'avais un
petit peu mal à la poitrine et donc je
décide d'aller consulter
je pars aux urgences
donc j'attends salles d'attentes et il
ya le docteur qui arrive est donc
elle arrive je fais je fais ma
consultation et à la fin de la
consultation jeudi
excusez moi mais je crois qu'on a fait
le lycée ensemble et donc froidement m18
je sais pour moi c'était impressionnant
pourquoi parce que moi j'aurais été
super fier de l'avoir docteur et on
s'attend généralement à dire et vous
qu'est-ce que vous êtes devenu dans la
vie c'est important pourquoi parce que
moi je peux être chef d'entreprise
un autre camarade peut devenir médecin
l'autre devenir chercheur et c'est ce
qui fera un peu votre force la force de
votre réseau à l'avenir et donc moi je
conseille un je conseille à tous les
jeunes de maintenir une relation saine
avec avec leur binôme leurs étudiants
leurs camarades de promo et et ça va
constituer à l'avenir
votre votre réseau qui permettrait de
développer peut-être votre secteur
développer l'économie de votre pays et
ça fera en sorte que fortifier et pour
revenir à à cela c'est à dire que moi
quand j'étais jeune je rêvais d'un d'une
entreprise qui s'appelle wall trade
center donc de tout jeune je voyais les
deux tours jumelles de new york des
attentats multiples en 95 puis en 2001
et s'était génialissime parce que ça
c'était le monde des affaires
internationales et il s'avère en
finissant mes études supérieures
un jour sur le journal je vois que wall
trade center algeria recruter donc je
dis mais c'est génial
d
l'organisme international est à alger je
pars pour faire un stage de fin d'études
et après après avoir fait mes six mois
de stage j'ai dû passer dix années je
suis resté pendant dix ans donc d'année
en année on se développe
on a eu la chance d'avoir j'ai eu la
chance peut-être avoir des mentors parce
que c'est important d'être guidé dans la
vie hein
il ya l'expérience des aînés qui nous
permet d'éviter certaines erreurs ou de
les commettre est à vous est donc se
faire corriger et même ce parcours
professionnel nous permet de encore
enrichir davantage notre réseau pourquoi
parce qu'on faisait partie d'un réseau
international d'un peu plus de 2 320 ou
un trade center à travers le monde et
que aujourd'hui en quittant le wat us
center et je suis entrepreneur
maintenant de pied depuis quatre cinq
années j'ai gardé ma ce réseau
international donc même dans nos actions
de promotion de du made in algeria parce
qu'on fait de la promotion des
exportations algériennes
on se retrouve à avoir un réseau à
l'international qui a vu notre parcours
qui a mais un petit peu score ce qu'on a
fait dans le temps et donc ça nous
permet de capitaliser toute cette
connaissance tout tout ce relationnel et
donc c'est pour ça que je vous dis que
c'est important et donc et c'est parti
d'un rêve
donc étant jeune j'admirais donc c'est
pour ça que je dis aux étudiants ou à
des jeunes rêvé de tout rêver de
l'impossible parce que tout est possible
quand on veut quand on est motivé quand
on a cette gnac de vouloir arriver à
quelque chose
peu importe les parcours peu importe les
difficultés un moment donné si on a un
objectif bien tracé sans le son le
sentir sans que sans s'en rendre compte
1 on développe cette résilience et cette
capacité d'aller se surpasser sur passé
tous les obstacles qu'on a dans la vie
et donc voilà c'est parti d'un rêve est
par contre ses rêves là dépendre aussi
d'une question qui est très très
importante 1
j'ai dit image de marque et force des
réseaux mais cette force des réseaux ne
peut s'entretenir que que si aussi ans
entretien nous mêmes commencent
entretien nous mêmes on n'a pas besoin
de de s'habiller en grandes marques
on n'a pas besoin de d'être on peut
chacun peut plus le faire même et on a
juste besoin d'un minimum et ce minimum
des fois répond à des standards c'est
c'est juste une tenue un comportement
une image qu'on véhicule tout le temps
là on parle quand on se dirige là on
rencontre des gens et quand on est jeune
on n'a juste pas conscience de l'impact
de notre image ou de notre comportement
sur peut-être notre avenir sur notre
relationnel avec les gens et du coup par
moments on fait des erreurs où on agit
d'une manière ou d'une autre dans les
conséquences pourraient être un petit
peu nuisibles tout est rattrapable
mais quand on peut éviter certaines
choses autant le faire et on n'a jamais
souvent accepter des indications de nos
aînés dont qui sont un peu démodé mais
souvent ils en raison et donc pour les
jeunes moi ce que je conseille
aujourd'hui à l'ère du digital à l'heure
du numérique où on est souvent
face à des réseaux les réseaux sociaux
notamment aux anges ou en divulguant
notre notre vie au quotidien etc
c'est aussi une partie de votre vie
c'est une partie de votre vie publique
pour laquelle il faut faire très très
attention et soit faire attention soit
essayer d'être vous même et souvent je
parle avec des jeunes qui
killer réseaux sociaux sont en mode
profil mais ces souches ou quelque chose
c'est on n'a juste pas parlé avec des
jeunes pour leur dire c'est pas grave
mettez votre photo de profil et votre
nom et prénom parce que c'est un nouveau
mode de vie c'est une ère qu'on doit
épouser pour laquelle il faut être soi
même et cette attitude là devrait vous
permettre de pouvoir vous assumez de
pouvoir vous vous montrez vert vers le
monde un monde qui est de plus en plus
digital de plus en plus connectés et
c'est franchement un impact sur votre
personnalité qui est important ça
permettra aussi de pouvoir vous montrer
naturellement au sur les différents que
ce soit facebook est peut-être un peu
privé linkedin qui est un peu
professionnel et twitter pour ceux qui
veulent émettre leur opinion parce que
c'est important aussi de penser de
réfléchir et de penser en dehors de la
boîte donc appelle couramment pensée
autres en dehors de la boîte et voilà
moi c'est grosso modo ce que je voulais
un peu parlé ces deux aspects qui ne
peuvent pas se dissocier donc développé
vous au maximum étudié soyez ouverts hao
monde et un esprit très ouvert
ne pas se limiter aux langues parce que
c'est un véhicule de savoir qui est très
très important ouvrez-vous à de la
culture générale en passant de dollar de
la musique de l'histoire de la politique
ça vous permet de vous enrichir et plus
vous êtes riche en culture générale plus
le contact vous sera facile avec les
gens parce que la connaissance le savoir
vous permet d'avoir de quoi échanger de
quoi débattre avec avec les personnes et
cela aussi est un facteur de
développement de votre réseau donc moi
je suis agréablement ravi d'être ici
parmi vous ça fait partie aussi du
développement d'un réseau un connaître
un artiste ou des étudiants ou des who
des chefs d'entreprise et rêver grand
donc c'est ce que j'avais à vous dire et
j'espère que vous aurez un avenir
radieux
merci